please play
boy is it
serious around here why does the cast
make stranger things season 4 look like
the most fun anyone's ever had
roller skating golf lessons ridiculous
pranks where do we sign up actually
we're in atlanta but we don't say that
number one this was one of the few times
the cast actually got to act off of
monsters and not stuff like tennis balls
on a stick the prosthetics were 90 real
for vechna the one thing added in post
was pulsing veins jamie campbell bowers
scene where henry transforms into vechna
was so creepy that it made millie cry
bower said i was just fervently going
through it and building it and it was a
lot i remember doing it in the rehearsal
and millie just looking at me and saying
something like you're a freak but it
gets worse while henry transformed into
vechna the speech he gave brought millie
to tears she was so freaked out bauer
admitted she was terrified like
literally terrified and when she saw
vecna she burst into tears and she said
that's not my friend i don't know who
this person is anymore where's he gone
bauer found the moment incredibly
challenging to not break because of how
shaken milly seemed but freaking her out
wasn't the only thing going wrong with
the prosthetics bauer also struggled
with finding the voice for vecna he had
a great voice when he wasn't in the
prosthetics but the second he put them
on it became really hard to hear but in
the end the voice he's using is all him
number two sadie sync is a rising star
like this is the most elaborate form of
harness harnessing that i've ever done
sadie's levitating stunt rehearsal
happened to allow her to get comfortable
using wires a common courtesy we imagine
isn't gifted to most actors it must have
been pretty unsettling with those white
contacts in or are her eyes just rolled
into the back of her head
[Music]
number three after being mostly bald for
her young teen life millie decided
enough was enough millie bobby brown
refused to shave her head for the role
again so she spent an hour in the makeup
chair getting the wig applied as opposed
to finn wolfhard who takes 20 minutes
for hair and makeup and he's ready to go
huh it must be nice to be finn and just
be able to sleep in in the morning
number four can roller rinks please make
a serious comeback the roller skating
scene was some of the most fun millie
bobby brown and noah schnapp had while
filming season 4. they loved it so much
they spent their break skating too at
one point the two actors slammed into
each other and crashed to the floor
accidentally causing an awkward groping
situation but that didn't deter them
from getting back up and skating some
more
number five taking an arrow to the knee
was so 2011. an arrow to the forehead
however is much more appealing whoa
yes finn took an arrow to the head and
managed to live to tell the tale sorry
that's so ridiculous every season of
stranger things does seem just a little
more ridiculous than the last doesn't it
number six need a hand there taker
getting taker montgomery's prosthetics
off at the end of the day was a sticky
mess is watching this making anybody
else nauseous it reminds us of the mind
flayer in eleven's leg
number seven and here we thought
contacts were supposed to help you see
better the designer had all the actors
do videos their first time trying out
the new white contact lenses just to
take the pressure off and add a little
fun to the experience because the lenses
were pretty trippy to wear oh maybe they
put contacts in you yeah were they
uncomfy yeah
number eight the costumes just keep
getting better with every season
and this season they're just epic how
are they going to top this for the next
one yeah we need to find out an outfit
that i get arrested in did you know
there could be up to five eddie munson's
filming at one time that's a nightmare
for the costume department who would
have to source five identical costumes
do you know how hard that is to do when
you're thrift shopping the kids dungeons
and dragons shirts were based on real
ones from the 1980s and were made by a
designer who actually plays the game
costume designer amy parris said the
duffer brothers were very specific about
wanting it to look handmade like it was
made by the kids and just a fun fact for
you when actors are running barefoot
it's actually up to the costume
department to find them nude shoes
number nine we only wish our jobs
required this kind of training huh
charlie heaton and eduardo franco had to
learn how to play golf for the show they
were whacking golf balls at an empty lot
in the desert eduardo admitted neither
of us had ever played golf so they took
them to a country club and they had to
dress the part eduardo went on to have a
crazy day of learning how to drive a
golf ball while he sipped on sodas and
charlie sipped on beer he found it oh so
satisfying to hear the ball pop when he
whacked it right but the irony of
learning to do it all right was that the
characters had to in eduardo's words
play the sport pathetically
number 10 free golfing shooting hoops
we're actually jealous of all the fun
they're having looks like for caleb
mclaughlin filming the basketball scenes
were a ton of fun and he's actually got
some pretty sick moves also that number
8 jersey he's sporting is in honor of
kobe bryant
number 11. this genuinely sounds like
torture
how did christopher get through this
sleeping christopher strand had his eyes
and mouth completely covered with
prosthetics and his hands tied to his
easy chair for the roll this meant he
couldn't see and he couldn't speak he
couldn't see he couldn't speak and he
could barely move in order to
accommodate him the best they could the
crew could only ask him yes or no
questions
so he could only communicate with a
slight nod or shake of the head
number 12
seriously now they're having freaking
water balloon fights what is this work
or play
children all of them yes we're feeling
an extreme case of fomo noah schnapp is
quite the prankster on set which is why
the entire cast and crew took it upon
themselves to seek revenge yes they
ruthlessly pummeled him with water
balloons
number 13. teenagers are destructive
little devils the most dangerous game of
pinata happened on set straight out of a
wrestling match came noah dealing the
final blow with a chair
number 14 this sounds like a good name
for a band
the scene where 11 was being bullied and
had a milkshake tossed on her was super
taxing on millie it put her in a super
sour mood she recalls 50 people there
laughing and pointing at her and the
bullying was so much she admitted i
remember feeling super distressed and
really sad she wasn't the only one
feeling sad either her co-star noah
schnapp also cried when he wasn't
supposed to milly said to him i don't
know if anyone knows that but you
actually got really upset do you
remember that you weren't meant to cry
in the scene you just got naturally
really emotional because it was actually
quite distressing to watch you've got
your good days and you've got your bad
days we guess
that's what makes tv dramatic number 15.
we don't need any old excuse to eat a
fruit by the foot on set millie
absolutely obliterated noah schnapp in
the fruit by the foot challenge noah
gagged and gave up but millie was seeing
this competition through to the end no
using no hands you have to eat it as
fast as you can it seems like everything
on set is upside down from what we're
seeing on tv with plenty of pranks games
and goofing off it's no wonder these
kids would rather be filming than in
high school if you could be part of any
of these moments this season which would
you have picked let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things
you